[Music]
todd is with us todd's in sacramento hey
todd welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
so um we are trying to buy some land
and um one of the thought one of the
process things that we're thinking about
was to sell our home and move into a
fifth wheel
and i was trying to figure out that
might be a good idea
um
me my wife and four kids
and so the thought process would be is
we would buy the land
and put the hookups on the property and
so we would be able to live there while
the house is being built
and then at conclusion of the house
being built we sell the house
we sell the trailer and uh trunk
how long is it gonna take you to build
the house
i'm assuming probably about a year
um i couldn't do that
i yeah the way i answer questions here
is what would i do
if i was in your shoes and it wouldn't
be that um okay
truthfully this sounds like a nightmare
um
the uh i mean there's a lot of people in
a little place a lot of people in a
trailer
a fifth wheel i mean you know i guess it
depends on your family maybe your family
is adventurous and they think this is
fun or something
my family would not think this is fun um
and my wife my wife would not be on
board with this i can just tell you and
so
and that enters into the discussion but
i mean uh
people do all kinds of things i've
talked to a guy not long ago he
bought a five thousand dollar used
mobile home
and for cash and uh you know took the
200 000 from the sale of his house
saved another hundred thousand and built
a 300 000 house took him three years and
he lived in that
little dumpy trailer for three years
while he was doing that i couldn't do
that
um so i can't and i i don't i'm one of
these
people that says i'm not going to ask
you to do something like dave rimsey
said
that i wouldn't do so because that's
hypocritical to me so
you can do it if you want to i won't say
that you're dumb or something
i would say you wouldn't buy a brand new
one because it's going to lose
you know half its thinking value when
you drive it off the lot
no our thought process would be truck
and trail would be probably about 40
grand total
yeah and then it's probably gonna be
worth 20 when you sell it
yeah and so we would lose some but as
my wife doesn't she she's the one who
brought the trailer up
and i thought she was initially kind of
crazy but she's been
your gut reaction was correct how old
are your kids
uh 10 8 4 and 10 months
yeah there's a zero percent chance this
ends well for anybody
this is not this is it's just real close
quarters for i think i'm going to go out
this another way
i would rent a house spend a little
money you know the you're going to lose
20 000
on this hookup anyway so i would rent a
house and lose my twenty thousand
dollars that way
um you're gonna lose your marriage and
at least two of those kids
at least two of one of them's gonna hurt
the other one but yeah the uh uh
i i i mean you again you're
if you pull this off and and come out of
it mentally healthy
and your marriage is healthy and
everything uh financially you're going
to be okay
but if you pull this off you would be an
unusual family
that pulls this off most people that did
this
would rue the day
at the end of it they're going my god
that was awful it sounds like a
one of those youtubification plans where
there's there's
always a youtube channel of somebody
doing something crazy
or a pinterest channel where somebody's
created a new
thing out of egg cartons and pony hair
or whatever weird thing
and it's just like oh we can do that and
you end up in a
mess and nobody likes you and your
neighbors want to burn your house it's
just like
man there's a reason why things work
most of the time right yeah i i you know
so
yeah i'm telling you i probably would
not do this
but it but i'm also not gonna just
absolutely tell you
not to do it if you choose to do it but
it's unusual
weird and so and the reason it is is
it's
a lot of people in a very close quarter
and
um it just doesn't sound fun i mean do
this if you do decide to do it email me
at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com because i'm going to
have you on my show and i'm going to
chronicle this with you follow him
through the year yeah